thank you to surfsharkvpn for sponsoring
this video the animation in pixar's soul
is absolutely stunning
if we compare this film visually to toy
story pixar's first film from 25 years
ago
it's clear that animation has made huge
strides in terms of what's possible
visually
there are a lot of elements that have
improved textures are more detailed in
higher definition
character models are more detailed
object physics and movements are more
realistic
and a lot of work has been done to make
the artificial cameras
look and feel more like real cameras
adding realistic camera shake and
movement in many
places but one of the most significant
changes and the one that stuck out to me
the most when i was watching
seoul was the light if we look back at
toy story we can see lighting and light
in the environment in use
the lighting is still relatively flat
and simple the light doesn't interact
with the atmosphere much the shadows are
pretty basic
and there's usually only one or two
light sources in a scene this is not to
criticize toy story pixar was doing
amazing work with the tools and
technology that were available at the
time
the way light is portrayed in toy story
had to do with technical constraints
rather than creative ability
but compare this light to souls i mean
look at this
rich warm delightful sunlight it's not
just a suggestion of sunlight it looks
real
i can almost feel its warmth reflections
colors highlights shadows everything has
the depth and complexity you would
expect
real world light to have this change
didn't happen overnight was soul though
if we look back through pixar's work
they've been making improvements to the
vibrancy of and how they use
light throughout the studio's history
just comparing the first toy story to
toy story 3 even shows impressive
improvements
one of the biggest leaps in terms of
bringing us the kind of lighting we see
in seoul was the development of ray
tracing technology
i'm not going to get into a technical
explanation of ray tracing but in basic
terms it allows rays of light to
actually be simulated in a digital
environment so adding a light source to
a scene
automatically produces reflections
bounce light and shadows
the upshot is that you can get much more
complex and realistic lighting with much
less work using ray tracing for example
in these shots see how each little light
bulb is creating its own reflection in
the pictures
this kind of reflection can be generated
almost automatically with ray tracing
but it would have been much more
difficult with traditional 3d lighting
another example of the improvement ray
tracing can provide is the movement of
multiple lights and shadows across
surfaces look at how the light and
shadow moves across the characters in
this shot from toy story
versus this shot on the subway from
seoul we can really see the changes that
ray tracing brought to the scene if we
compare
brave the last pixar film made without
ray tracing to monsters university the
first pixar film to use the technology
the lighting in brave looks good but
in monster's view there's a clear shift
in the quality of the light
especially environmental lighting in
this scene from brave the torches on the
wall look like they're producing light
but they don't really look like they're
actually lighting the environment
compare that to this scene from monsters
university where it genuinely feels like
all the little lights in the scene
are lighting the scene beyond the
improving tools and technology there's
also
large teams and an incredible amount of
attention to detail that goes into
producing the lighting on a pixar film
for example on seoul cinematographer
bradford young whose credits include
arrival selma and solo was brought on to
consult for a variety of aspects of
shooting the film
one being how to light the skin tones of
the black characters and like a real
film set lighting has to be considered
throughout the whole process
in the same way a location manager might
choose a location because
of its access to beautiful natural light
to practically motivate light in an
animated scene there has to be
lights or windows built into the digital
set and the people responsible for
camera movement and composition have to
keep lighting in mind and communicate
with the lighting leads
but for pixar all this effort and the
push for better and better lighting
is not just an avenue to make the films
prettier but one to
allow light to actually play an
increasingly important role
in the story for example look at how the
change in the intensity and color of the
light illuminating joe as a cat helps
cue the emotional arc
of this scene in seoul lighting is used
to help create a clear separation
between the grape before
and earth in the grape before the light
is very soft and diffused it doesn't
have a clear
source and it is very cool in color
on earth harder sunlight creates
interesting complex shadows and
sparkling highlights
look for example at the spectral
highlights on the passing l train or the
harsh
shadows underneath the car these are the
kinds of details that you won't see
in the great before here the source of
the light is often clear
sunlight mixes with practical lighting
fixtures in the digital sets to produce
beautiful rich environments but this
separation isn't just something that
helps define the two places for the
audience
it also plays a crucial role in the
storytelling direct practical sunlight
is associated with earth
as 22 steps out into the world for the
first time in joe's body
22 reacts to the bright sunlight it's
something new that 22 hasn't
experienced before while joe who's
experienced this many times doesn't
react
at all as a side note characters
responding like this like when joe the
cat responds to the warmth of this patch
of sunlight
helps sell the illusion of the light
being real and it illustrates how
lighting
and story have to work together early on
in the process
so soul is creating an association
between direct light with a clear source
and earth but then it also uses this
kind of light to cue
someone's spark when joe plays the piano
early in the film he is backlit by
sunlight coming through a window
this is mirrored later when connie plays
trombone and stands up
into a similar backlight the youth
seminar is a world of
concepts and abstractions souls find
their spark in the hall
of everything but while this hall has
pizza you can't really
taste it the hall might have every
earthly object and activity but there is
still something you can't
find in the hall of everything
[Music]
in this moment light is used to help cue
a spark
that kind of light that is not something
we ever see in the youth seminar
reinforcing the idea that
22 spark had to be found on earth
that 22 spark wasn't an abstract concept
but something as tangible as the warmth
and beauty of sunlight
but the spark is not just the object of
the seed or the light streaming through
the trees
it's all of these things it's the
feeling produced by this
mundane beauty the idea that this thing
exists that there is something that is
not found in the hall
of everything but that exists on earth
in this moment
essential to the film's philosophy and
premise
and because this thing isn't a concept
or object it's not something that can be
described in the film
it's a feeling it has to be evoked in
the audience
joe's later realization that 22's spark
was the joy of everyday living while he
looks at this seed would have had less
impact if the way the backlight
illuminates the veins in the seed wasn't
so genuinely
beautiful the beauty of the film's
naturalistic lighting on earth
in contrast to the pretty but more
conceptual abstract feeling of the great
before
helps communicate the film's philosophy
that there's a unique
important quality to life on earth that
lies
outside of abstraction and concepts
that there's a value in everyday living
outside of our list of accomplishments
and that would be a difficult concept to
convey if you couldn't show
that beauty 22 spark is getting to
experience
the beauty of such a simple moment and
for the audience to believe it
and feel it that moment had to actually
be beautiful
one of the most important ingredients in
the beauty of this moment
is the light
[Music]
this video is sponsored by surf shark
vpn use code thomasflay or click the
link in the description to get 83
off and three months for free of your
subscription to
surfsharkvpn vpns are services that
allow you to route all your internet
traffic through servers all around the
world this can have a lot of privacy and
security benefits and allow you to take
back some of the control and privacy of
your internet usage from your isp
you can avoid things like location based
price discrimination or
region locked streaming content if you
live in a country that bands or blocks
certain internet services or websites
vpns are a crucial tool for getting
around censorship
surfsharkvpn is an affordable vpn with a
lot of great features and
a 30-day money-back guarantee one of my
favorite surfshark features is that on
their windows application you can
whitelist
certain applications so one application
can be routing through the vpn while
another is running through your normal
internet click the link in the
description or use the code
thomasflight to get 83 off your
subscription
and three months for free thanks again
to surfshark for supporting this video
and making it possible
[Music]
you